on Friday December 8th one Championship
presents a night of Muay Tha is the
world's greatest St ERS display the art
of a
limbs kickboxing world champion Roman
crica sets his sights on the inaugural
heavyweight Muay Tha World
title plus the debut of 17-year-old
Phenom Johan
gazali the best strikers in the
world one fight night 17 on Prime
video ride through the city like BR I'm
on a mission to get it all ride through
the city like
like and now
Brandon
six Good morning
Vietnam it is December 4th at
7:01
a.m. we got the morning crew the morning
crew doing the morning shift only an uh
well it's about two hours earlier than
we usually do there how you guys feeling
about the morning grind I like it man do
you let's get it going all right I like
the energy chin you look a little sleepy
I mean it's dark outside still it's
still is a little dark man your boy uh
usually up around 4 maybe 5 if I get to
sleep in so it's all gravy here man all
gravy it's been a long weekend my son's
first travel ball team's uh tournament
play so you're playing some pretty good
freaking teams man you're not playing in
that little little league around the
court anymore these kids are not white
and they've been playing
forever they don't miss it was a good
learning experience for the team good
learning experience for my son he
dominated at the last league but they
were all white kids so he got hit with a
fresh wet dick in the face by these kids
who are not white and can play them some
ball okay it's a good learning
experience for him now uh travel ball
team in case you guys don't know they're
comprised of the best of the best in the
area and then they're not associated
with the league they're all allstars
from that league and then they travel
around and play other all-star teams um
and it's uh it's a it's pretty Cutthroat
pretty Cutthroat and so we weren't
supposed to win a single game in our
first tournament and these boys pulled
it off they won one but we did play the
I think the 90th ranked team of the
nation I might as well not even show it
up they beat the breakes off of us but
the boys held their composure and they
rallied in the second game and won a
game they beat the crap out of that team
and then there's just something missing
on Sunday because they they went one and
one and then they made it to the Sunday
game Sunday I don't know what's going on
the boys were just off maybe they don't
like to play on the Lord's day but the
bats weren't connecting and they uh they
got dealt with man they got dealt with
I'll tell you right now though I've done
a lot of cool things in my life from
football fighting stand up nothing is
better than when your kid is playing
freaking Little League Baseball oh my
God it is so fun man and out of all the
sports he gravitates towards baseball
I'm all for it I don't have a background
in baseball so I can just kind of chill
and when when he you know he still does
ji- Jitsu that's kind of my thing a
little bit there football kind of my
thing so with this um you know you're
not this over aggressive like come on
you know so uh my role in that just
mindset you know I can I can help him
out with that that he has a huge
Advantage CU his dad knows something
about competing so that's where I
can kind of take the papa bear role but
it is the absolute best man it's the
best I'm going have to cut back on uh
touring for sure I got to figure that
out I struggle with that struggle with
that when I was younger I could tour you
know three four weekends a month and um
you know I wasn't missing a ton but now
like I'm in Chicago this week I missed
this second tournament you know I miss
the second tournament so I don't know I
really struggle with it so I'll figure
it out man there has to be a happy
medium there but there's nothing I uh
love more than watching that kiddo play
baseball especially when he has success
he hit a bomb in that second game dude
only seven-year-old to get it to the
warning tracks and then when I went over
to him I'm like that's what I'm talking
I always say tea time tea time that's
what I'm talking about he looks at me he
goes Dad if that was in Colorado that's
a home run cuz cuz we play the video
game I always tell him the balls go
further in Colorado high altitude I was
like dude you are so right man but
that's not home run in California dude
all right so keep running um but yeah
nothing better dude and dude I'm full
dad mode I mean I'm chilling in the
right field with other dads we're
talking shop some dad brought some Bruce
Skies they have the lawn
chairs these other these dads and
they've been in it cuz they have older
kids so they they got the grill going
dude yeah man I might just P up dude
pull up yeah I'm like who's that I'm
like st's Uncle you know cuz you can't
just be that's the guy works with me can
you have some hot dogs can you get some
dogs on there man he's hungry today yeah
it's it's uh there's nothing better it
it's crazy though when you see some of
these kids at 7even you know like my son
it is what it is I'm sure every dad
thinks this he's an outlier you know he
he can he can play some ball dude
there's some kids though they whatever
it is you know they just have it and
they have that Competitive Edge and
there's seven in this pitcher this dude
this kid was thick I'm talking John Kook
like John Daly of baseball at the mount
I'm like look at this kid Cano anybody
bro this kid was throwing junk at seven
I
mean yesterday struck
out [__] four
Innings you know 12 in a row I mean no
one could hit this little kid's thing
just balling dud balling didn't care
went back to the Dugout eating his
Cheetos God go a baller dude baller but
that but that seven that just have like
that tenacity like it's cool man it's
cool to see I absolutely love it we
started early today cuz I had to take
the lightning to the shop we got to be
there around 8:30 get this bad boy
running so I am crunked got the parts
from LMR so hopefully this lightning
gets back up and running if not it's a
disaster but it sounds like this is all
that we need and then it's Off to the
Races Daddy I got some cool stuff in the
works I can't wait to show you guys a
lot of truck stuff car stuff coming up
this week and next week Casey is
exhausted you're working double time
it's all good though you're getting
education in cars yeah man spark plugs
fuel pumps yeah torque that's all I got
Ah that's where I that's where I draw
the line yeah yeah it's interesting
though I mean uh you know there I know
my trucks and cars like but I don't like
there's gear heads and you've been
around it where there's a complete
different like I'm a super newbie yeah
as far as like when it comes like
Building engines and all that mechanical
work dude yeah like Ryan at Kibby Tech
starts talking and I'm just like glay is
over like yeah thumbs up yeah I got it
dude yeah it's a cool world though man I
I freaking love it I love it absolutely
love it and then also with you
know with my son I take him on all the
car stuff whenever I buy a car or do
anything car I always bring with
me because this younger generation come
up with all electrical
stuff and it's it's I don't have any
issue with electric it's
just it's not good so I tell my son is
he'll be like go Dad is that Tesla
faster than this or is that electric car
faster I yeah yeah it is I said uh just
because it's faster doesn't mean the
build quality or the amount of work that
goes into it is good I said so your
steak tonight I can cook it faster than
the microwave or I can go old school and
put on that fire grill which would you
rather have he's like the grill like
that's the difference between gas Power
and Electric just because it gets maybe
quarter mile faster doesn't mean it's
better there's a lot that goes into them
man so they hate Teslas every time see a
Tesla my four was
boo boo so yeah we'll see how that goes
but uh as far as fight game goes man uh
still the offseason for the most part
still the offseason but UFC Austin uh
came through through in fashion it was a
uh lot of controversy but some great
fights lot of finishes Austin
always always does the job they always
stack Austin Austin's uh the UFC does a
good job obviously Rogan lives there
Rogan was in the audience watching as a
spectator you had Tom seura there um so
yeah man you had a lot going on there so
they always stack those uh UFC Austin
it's also called UFC Austin it's not
just like UFC fight it's UFC Austin so I
think that the biggest gate there that
they've ever had in history I saw Dana
White on Instagram yeah so that's pretty
impressive Austin's a big big market for
them so they definitely stack it with
some good fights especially for a fight
night this thing was good uh the night
was a little if if Armen uh tarukan
didn't absolutely demolish uh darush
with that fake knee with the right hook
which is insane dude insane he at least
Le took the momentum back cuz before
that you had Jaylen Turner and Bobby
green and this kind of overshadowed a
great night of fights because the ref
went yeah but did he die and we're like
no he's like damn uh that ref there's a
couple jobs where we can kind of have
brain farts and you know kind of take
your time uh if you're an open heart
surgeon probably not if you're a chef
not the end of the world if you you know
burn the steak uh if you're a mechanic
kind of go at your own pace if you're
NFL quarterback you got to get moving if
you're a a ref in the UFC you got to be
on your stuff man you can't have a brain
fart or just zone out or try and see
somebody die that's what this guy did
with with Jaylen Turner Bobby green when
the guy is defensive uh on his stomach
and look going
unconscious I'm trying to remember I'm
trying not to be a uh a victim of the
moment here um a prisoner of the moment
as they say in
colleges this might be the worst
stoppage I've seen late stoppage can you
think of another one I mean yamasaki was
notoriously known for but his was always
like ah come on this one you're like
what's happening right now the Y want to
see a dead body yeah the Priscilla
kosher I think versus Valentina that was
bad but she was still awake but it was
like she they should have stopped it cuz
she was getting destroyed but this one
was like this one was way this one was
more d Bobby was out I bet you that ref
when he was walking the loot was like
y'all want to see a dead body like what
he's like watch this watch this watch
this it's a no dude we don't it was
terrible dude it doesn't help the sport
um yeah that that was and you and me
especially you chin always like early
stoage let it go live to fight another
day especially for title fights though
that I'm always like title fights I I'm
in agreement with you unless it's like
if this was a title fight of course not
but usually title yeah like or know your
fighter like Dom Cruise fight right like
some of that stuff is a little dicey um
this one I mean dude what are you doing
yeah I felt so bad for Bobby horrible
yeah horrible horrible Jaylen Turner is
absolute Savage takes on short notice
and then just dismantles Bob he didn't
want to take the fight he was like super
upset it's hero yeah the from the same
part of California uh Fontana oh no I
think uh well somewhere in sanino is not
Fontana I don't think so are you sure
yeah bring that up
I thought it was
Fontana San
berino but their gyms out of
Fontana oh but they're from
uh that's like that that area which yeah
yeah so he was like you let you the you
know the blueprint the Trailblazer and
then I guess that's how you treat the
Trailblazers right shout out to the
Overland High School Trailblazers in nor
Colorado I went to high
school uh um yeah Jaylen Turner did but
again you can't be mad at Jaylen Turner
because that's it's on the ref like
you're literally trained you don't stop
till he pulls you off it's just it it's
you're just conditioned that way it is
what it is uh figorito looked fantastic
at his bantamweight debut he's going to
be a problem and font was what eighth
seventh or eighth so he's up there man
he's going to be a problem he absolutely
dismantled Rob font he looked fantastic
I thought he looked a little slow a
little tentative at first and then he
got his he got his bearings and he
looked phenomenal yeah you're at eight
he's eight yeah so there's some good
fights some really big fights that
bantamweight division is tasty good
God especially got figorito in there now
he is that is a tasty
division man might be the best division
the UFC it's right up there uh then
Shawn
Brady um I mean he you could have done
some of the they didn't give it to him
because the the judges don't know
grappling or fighting so that's cool but
um there could have been some tense
seven rounds there I thought um the
crowd was booing Sean Brady saying F you
Brady they went oh oh you don't like
when I just dominate a guy in Mount and
have his back control for literally 15
minutes F Brady cool check this out he
dou Cura um I thought Kelvin Gaston
pretty good at welterweight too tough
test man and you have that long layoff
you're cutting down to a division when
he's been a middleweight for a hot
second he's always should have been a
welterweight the guy had all the
potential in the world to be a world
champion at welterweight and they're
like cool man come back to welterweight
here's Shawn Brady I think uh if
anyone's justified in this fight
especially how good sha Brady looked was
uh B muhamad and he tweeted out goes I
thought Shawn Brady sucked that's how
good Bal is he absolutely owned Shawn
Brady everyone's like ah it's just cuz
Shawn Brady's not that good it's first
loss 15 and one like yeah he's not that
good and then Shan Brady goes out there
and completely dominates Kelvin Gaston
and bah was like what's up I thought sha
Brady wasn't it very good so kudos to
him sha Brady had a smart smart call out
he goes if Ian Gary beats vente luk let
me let me let me dominate your boy there
I'm like that's a pretty good call out I
could see that happening too see that
happening that's a good fight it's a
really good
fight uh Klay guita did you watch that
one chin of course did you have Klay
Guida winning that I kind of had it like
uh like up in the air we're a little
biased though right did you know anybody
that Roots against Clay
Guida I I would have gave it to him but
I'm also you know from the clay Guida um
era so maybe that's what's going on
there he's like 41 and he's still
killing it it's pretty crazy still great
cardio Misha Tate looked good one face
grank shout out to Misha Tate one of our
favorites dude and then how about this
is how crazy Austin was backto back KO
slams via Rampage
style from a triangle these boys are
forgetting to grab that leg with you
know you go to you got to reach under
and grab the ankle so he can't get
lifted you just forgot one guy tried to
remember like oh no and just missed and
then got slammed backto back slams when
that's never happened
before and Dan Hardy's uh wife won she
had a touching postf fight speech too
about Dan Hardy
Veronica Hardy she she looked great man
so I love those two love is real dude I
think Georgie mentioned that she's only
28 she's like pretty damn young not that
young I mean you know she's only 30 no
you believe that I think because uh you
know there's like 18year olds in the U
no cuz it's cuz Dan Hardy is like 40 I
think what 41 what are you doing I'm
just saying no piece of [__] that's fine
what are you doing here that's perfectly
fine I'm just saying like you guys
realize how young she is you know Dan
Hardy's 40 she's 30 I thought she was
problem with that that's all I thought
she was when Dan Hardy was 10 she was
one are we okay with
this you don't say [__] about Jerry
Seinfeld though real quiet on
that by the way Bobby green Wow way to
turn it chin Bob should be of note uh
you know she's only 30 it's an
interesting fact that's all a God I mean
if she was like 22 or 23 yeah might
bring it up you know she's 2 which is
completely legal you know she's 23 and
Dan hard 40 I'm like hm that's cool yeah
so like KY dude little note here there's
like you know Verona R is
30 oh wow okay yeah that's fine Dan
Hardy's 40 and that's a great yeah
that's a great relationship nice try
dude sorry Dan Hardy had some haters
here at the studio there's not haters a
fun thing great win of note uh she's 30
Dan Hardy's 40 just want to throw that
out there on the biggest night of her
life
and here I am I was like love is real
man love is cool yeah it is she's 30
though all right she's like right I mean
it's not like this cool number where if
she's like 21 or if she's 40 that we
even bring up age here 28 like that's a
grown ass woman fighting the UFC she
married a 40-year-old no that's like
that's a 13ear age gap which is great I
dated a girl that was 14 years younger
than me I'm not saying anything's wrong
with it I just didn't know she was that
young and you whatever's she's not that
young though that's the that's why I
think it's a stupid note all right fine
we just had fun talking by the clay
Guida age that's fun to bring up cuz
he's doing the thing maybe I mixed up
clay with with Hardy it's uh it's not a
thing I see you searching chin I see I
know I know it's the offseason of the
UFC and we're searching right now but
that's where I draw the line well real
quick you're right Bobby green does
train out of uh Fontana which is in I
didn't know it was in San Bernardino
yeah man yeah
suin what they do with cukin he was
eight just knocked out the number four
guy in a minute his only loss is to the
world champion Islam makev and that was
his first fight in UFC on short notice
and I think it was by decision what do
you do let me see that let me see that
lineup wait islon uh no the lightweight
bud just go down you're at
pound-for-pound there we go so
eight suin he lost a
gamrot he just beat
four in all actuality you would
do Dustin por but Dustin por is at that
Legacy level that Legend level where he
doesn't fight just the contenders he he
only fights the super
fights but if he wants wanted to
actually make a run for the for like the
legit title you would do uh suian versus
Dusen por I don't know if po takes that
fight though because he's at that level
now where he can pick and choose which
is good and bad if it's up to me it's up
to me if I'm Dana and I'm hanging out
with busting with the boys and the nek
boys and I was in his shredded body with
all those supplements I would do Ben MOA
St
Denise versus
suin good luck beating
benois BSD BDSM what's up dude he is a
complete Savage you could do
that but then again is suin like hold up
I just be the number four guy I'm
fighting 11 so our boy uh BDSM is gonna
have to do some work but he's getting I
I mean in a year he's gon to be top
five that guy is such a
monster overall good card though man
what else you got chin oh but by the way
Dan other hater notes no there's not
hating dude I uh before we move on uh
just want to remind everybody Dana
slapped his wife a year ago so I just
want to you know I just want to be very
clear and his wife is 12 years
younger
uh anyway D Danny White did say Arman
suian after that win because it was so
dominant he's like it does throw wrench
into the title picture for that weight
division well so you got makev and
Charles Charlie Charlie Olive fighting
right
yeah you the the rest of the division so
you got these these the next crop of
guys just
just idling ready to [__] take off so
you
got the older heads older heads Charlie
Olive Justin gatei Dustin por darush and
Chandler top
five then you got the younger crew the
next wave which is gamrot FIV
serian and uh BDSM
Ben was St Denise they got Jaylen Turner
there yeah those boys are the next wave
and boy are their names all sorts of
jumbled
up I I agree with Dana time to get some
fresh blood in there I can only see
Justin gatei poier darush Chandler
Charlie Charlie Olive fight makev so
many times let's let's I I like that
wrench in there and there's be another
wrench with BDSM coming in hot BDSM hot
angry dude
hot so I'm sure you watch uh BDSM when
he was 17 got arrested for theft that's
chin
today oh my
God anyway uh so bkfc over the weekend
Mike Perry once again has CH of note
Mike Perry about two years ago found out
he was 1% black and did use the nword he
did have a great fight Saturday night he
made another person quit which is crazy
dude I mean
the myth of Mike Perry
continues I mean did did you see the
postf fight press conferences both their
faces oh I have the yeah were bigger
than both our heads Jen so that's Mike
Perry's face right here look how swollen
it is it's yeah right here and then this
is Jimmy Rivera which is jacked up but
then Eddie Alvarez I mean his face was
just jacked up Yeah Eddie alz looks like
an extra from The Sopranos when they're
you know dud yeah like his eye socket I
mean literally but so Eddie didn't call
it quit his coach Mark Henry who's one
of the best in the game okay the very
best was like look at his eye he's like
no we're done we're out you see him go
no we're done and the rest Corn's like
no no no and Eddie's like no no no he's
like nope we're out we're done and he's
he's just looking out for his fighter
it's the right choice especially bear
knuckle you know so Kudos Demar kenry
shout out to Mark Henry one of the best
to ever do it but he looks at it
longevity EDD he's done it all it's all
good we don't live to fight another day
if there is another day fighting for him
which I sounds like Mike Perry and him
might do a rematch in North Philly North
Philadelphia born and raised
so yeah yep that beer knuckle man that's
that's what it is that's what it is
devastating to your face that's what it
is just hats be knuckle MMA dog what's
up man most violent sport on Earth I
condone that oh hell yeah is it yeah I
see you looking liking
dude Ms would all send it to me hell
yeah um yeah Beck Rollins got dealt with
huh MH that was tough 50 45 and bear
knuckle is not fun not a fun night in
the office Jeremy Stevens beat Jimmy
Rivera Jimmy was doing really well
though but I know dude
yeah second round yeah dude Mike Perry
Mike Perry did a smart call out this is
the thing about bear knuckle there's a
guy who's their champ who's like the
legit champ but he's not famous so the
owner of Bear Knuckles bringing in WWE
guys to like help with their
personalities that's either you got it
or you don't there's nothing we can do
because then it's just on natural it's
like this weird WWE gimmick so I don't
know if that's the move either you have
it or you don't UFC's done this for
years some guys just don't have it but
their skill set is what makes him star
so you kind of got to rely on that so
you know the owner of bkfc wants a you
know 12 Mike Perry's it's just it
doesn't work like that it doesn't work
like that so for Mike Perry he made a
smart call out I saw him call out U
Anthony
Pettis and just Mike Perry beating up
these UFC
Legends yeah dude and like making him
quit dude making Luke rockold quit and
freaking Eddie alvare that's insane
making Eddie Al wait hold on to be very
clear nice try to be very clear Eddie Al
think quit his coach markk Henry was
like nope I mean by quit I mean they're
not going to continue fighting he made
his team throw in the towel Eddie didn't
you know quit he would have kept going
he he'll go till you kill him that ref's
like
you then you're my guy um did you see
the kiss with his wife like after as
well Eddie alvare and his wife it was
kind of weird but W is that what they
did she just looked like she was just
like in a days and they just kissed yeah
cuz her husband's in beer knuckle it's
traumatizing Jen you know
he's right after his she was just
smiling like she's probably just like
holy crap what are we
doing what else you got
dude um all right so I don't know if I
want to show these videos but did you
see the Bobby green Arman suken yeah I
heard arook and talk about it he was
saying where he comes from if you talk
stuff you got to back it up so they just
both pushed each other and then it was
over no it so um Bobby green was on Theo
and he was saying like like I I don't
want to fight someone like Armen stukin
he's so boring all he does is take it
down blah blah so then you know
obviously it got to Armen and then Armen
confronted him at a hotel but the crappy
part about this is like Armen had his
whole team with him and there's like
this other guy was like in Bobby's face
Bobby's like hey back away tell your boy
to back away and then they did that
shoving thing later on Bobby and his
team found that dud and smacked him in
the face which I'm like I I like that
yeah I get down with it the only thing
with army is like where I come from if
you're going to talk smack you going get
punched in the face it's like no I get
that but it's not like it's just fight
talk yeah he didn't like you're in the
same division he's like he's boring
right I'm not a fan I'll knock him out
god dude I don't think he knock him out
he said like he was boring yeah if we
can't talk any stuff without you
approach Us in the hotel take it easy
man yeah especially if you're not
supposed to fight what are we
doing uh so this made the headlines and
a lot of UFC fighters a lot of Fighters
are pissed off about this headline
because it's so how about TMZ how about
TMZ cuz we all know when you say so the
headline is X UFC champion Jamal Hill
arrested for domestic violence right
away your mind goes a man hit a chick
yeah domestic violence is associated
with man hitting a woman every single
time
99.9999% of the time when's the headline
that's what you get it should say x UFC
champion Jamal Hill arrested for
argument with brother older brother too
I think older
brother and Sean stri had a great quote
he said if you've never fought your
brother you're not Brothers me and my
dude I'm one in 1500 against my brother
but that one was
[Music]
sweet uh Sean Shin but you can get a
domestic violence charge for find your
brother uh L M AO I guess I've dodged
some domestic violence charges if you
haven't fight your brother you ain't
Brothers bottom line facts he added to
it too though but Jam Hill you're your
brother be a batch for calling the cops
he might not be your brother after that
batch move just saying yeah who calls
the cops unless he was like terrified
get his ass I wonder what happened Jamal
Hill you know he always goes pretty hard
in the pain on his uh YouTube show which
is a great show shout out Jamal Hill but
um he's smart because lawyer is like
dude be cool and Jamal Hill was like I
just can't wait for all the facts to
come out you guys are going to see I'm
sure it was a just a argument between
brothers who doesn't fight their
brothers it's just when you're 30 though
when you're 30 like still fight your
brother hold on that's a damn good point
I didn't think about that I just
remember I was talking to the guys I'm
like we all fought our brothers yeah
when we were kids my brother fight now
we're two I have I have three kids you
know that's a good point that's a good
point yeah a lot of jealousy he went
home for the holidays I'm you know he's
champ he's doing the damn thing you know
it's not like he lost he's still champ
he just Rish the Bell or they took it
cuz he blew out his Achilles so there
could be some jealousy there which is
always happens in families or close
friends so we'll find out eventually the
tough thing is when your brother's UFC
fighter and you have
jealousy okay fight me you
know not good when's the last time you
fought your brother like how
old 20s high school high school yeah
even college no you don't
fight all righty when time me fight your
brother yeah I was a high school too
you're all
Thanksgiving I [__] him up Bron he
[__] me up every single
time yeah but High School yeah I I'm I'm
I'm like I was 0 in 15 1500 and then one
day dude I just had the bridge and I bit
him and I I fought him dude I fought him
I won best victory of my life he goes be
my brother at one time then Crow
cop yeah Crow cop legendary yeah beat my
brother more legendary what else you got
uh so Ian Gary uh posted this this and
I'll just play it for you it's just on
his Instagram more people talk more
people talk the harder I
work got more people to prove wrong this
is what I want to see it's not fuing me
yes pissing me off
yes his
face
demons yes get mad young grasshopper I'm
going have to win a a middleweight World
title before I win the welterweight well
I tell you
boom this is what I want to see out of
Ian Gary man he can Channel all this and
become the biggest star in the UFC he
just has to play his cards right and he
has to win he has to win but now there's
a there's a whole narrative there
there's a whole narrative Leon and Sean
Strickland you know so I'm all for it
now turning comments off usually
isn't good the last guy I saw do this
was Logan Paul the difference is Logan's
out of a level where he never has to
work ever again and doesn't have to win
any fights and his WWE stuff's all
scripted so he doesn't have to worry
about it he's at such a massive level he
can turn his comments off I still don't
suggest it for Ian
though it's going to be a tough pill to
swall but and it take it from a a guy
who deals with a
lot as long as they're talking about you
it's it's it's good you know the the the
great you know all all press is good
press even at this level because that he
was the focal point for two weeks of the
UFC Community the MMA community and so
now everyone's G to have their opinions
most people are going to say whatever
he's a cuck then some people like God
you guys are stupid either way he's
getting more fans and more haters which
equals pay-per-view which equals money
but when you disengage go nope I can't
take it turn comments off well then
people like all right they stop engaging
so then you stop trending so this is
going to make Ian Gary massive massive
is if he wins if he loses this that this
is his story unfortunately this is it
but if he wins which I I would bet a ton
of money that he does pull it off and
and now I see that now he's motivated
even more and angry Ian Machado
Gary trouble dude trouble because like
he was upset against Neil Magny he
tortured Neo Magny he could put him away
he decided to torture him so for viente
LC like damn what are you guys doing
dude so we'll see man but this has all
the the the Groundlings the the
blueprint to this could be a great great
story man great story him him and his
wife winning the End by him being double
world champion that's what I think
happens for
him right on thank God he's
talented we take a little
break oh boy listen this episode of the
shop show at 7:00 a.m. is brought to you
by DraftKings you got the NBA popping
you got college football you got the
Bowl championship series Florida State
you knew damn well you shouldn't be in
there you have your third string
quarterback even the second string came
in you beaten Alabama you beaten
Michigan you beat in Texas nah man
that's why you guys are doing what I'm
doing and I'm going to be watching the
games all right that's what you're doing
Ohio state has an argument I'll give him
that all right um but I'm excited for
the the BCS Championship I think they
got it right don't add me it is what it
is I didn't do anything all right in the
NBA is popping my nuggets are balling
but you can watch college football you
can watch the UFC at the Apex Center
this Saturday you can watch one
Championship watch the NBA and make Bank
bro with DraftKings all right this
season the NBA is so freaking good and
new customers you can score 150
instantly in bonus bets just for betting
five bucks on basketball win or lose you
get an instant dub download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
the code shop show new new customers can
get 150 instantly in bonus bets for
betting just five buckaroos on
basketball only on draftking Sports week
with the code shop show Casey's got this
the crown is yours Casey hit it Vape
daddy gambling problem call 1800 Gambler
in New York call 8778 heny or text heny
467 369 and West Virginia visit www.1
1800 gambler. net please play
responsibly in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
where you're from that's where that is
where I'm from and I would call
8887895118
hours after issuance terms at
sportsbook.com basketball terms
yes
fume what else you have chin uh a little
bit more on Ian Gary so uh Brenan Allen
Savage did an interview I guess he did
train with uh Ian before or he had the
same camp before or same team and then
um he said that he actually Ian got KO
like bad and then there's video footage
of it but he's not going to show he's
not going to say the name of who the who
it is oh you do
yep I might have sawv the
footage all right well yeah so that's
that but also Brandon Allen Leon Edwards
whoever we talking about practice we
talking about practice you talking about
practice we talking about practice I
know some guys who were just Journeymen
in the UFC and knocked out some of your
favorite world Champs and then those
World Champs said cool story but's
practice and then went on to dominate
dominate in the the UFC it's practice
[__] happens that's why you're
practicing cuz those Champs go okay you
caught me with that head kick not going
to happen in the real fight I don't give
a [__] we're talking about practice and
it's like vice versa too right some
people are awesome in the gym but they
can't perform you know on the big stage
ton of people ton of
people okay um so Danny White was on the
Neel boys podcast and he said there's
going to be a big super fight in 2024
but it doesn't involve McGregor and then
your boy was
trending I'm coming up I want the world
to know I made that fight up Joe um yeah
then I just randomly was like I was just
looking at doing my research my sources
okay I I I did go to my sources by
sources I mean myself in my underwear at
4:00 a.m. just scouring Instagram I
looked at GSP I'm like this dude's
getting in shape why is he getting in
such good shape and then I went oh he
had that grappling tourament but they
called it off and people like yeah he
was hurt I'm like was he or was UFC like
hey bud you're going pretty hard in the
paint for this [__] grappling
competition how about you just put on
some small 4 o gloves and we'll get you
right back in the cage and he was like I
might be down for that like yeah and
guess who else wants to do it the guy
you're supposed to
Grapple Nick Diaz is also down same
thing you're just putting on some 4 o
leather gloves instead of just grappling
for 15 minutes you're actually going to
punch each other in the face and get
paid way more money they both went amen
and then Dana watched my show at 9:00
a.m. live last week and went holy [__]
chob I've always loved you and made this
fight and is trending everywhere it's so
hilarious people like oh what are your
sources I'm like there are none dude but
it's going to fruition you [__] oh it's
h hilarious we'll see I don't even know
if that's the fight he's talking about
it could be uh Michael Venom paage and
Kevin
Holland yeah uh so Kevin Holland did say
like he wasn't offered anything but I
mean they could be working on it you
never know well it was on your board
yeah I mean do they you think they do it
per go ahead dude of course yeah go
ahead and ask ask your question I
mean I feel like they do but I'm just
asking of course they do okay you think
this $4 billion company has the
interviews and like
oh our secrets are behind us oh no
someone actually asked Dana at the press
conference about that and he's like he
just completely like shoved it off like
he's like no I'm not talking about it it
makes more interesting think about all
the staff that has going there set up
for the interview are they like oh are
we missing anything in here you got
Dana's coffee we you guys water yeah
soone like dude you left all the secret
matchups right behind
Dana and it happens all the time time so
it's it's it's them trolling I think but
then also them getting a gauge on how
interested people are into these
fights because Kevin Holland Michael
Venom paage kind of trending now or if
people see something on there like a get
out of here man you know so uh it's 100%
on purpose and I love it I absolutely
love
it so Dana says Kevin Holland reveals if
there's truth behind Michael Venom paage
fight at UFC 297 Dana White does this is
saying lion mother effers claiming the
prime card did 1.3 million pay-per-view
buys I'm sorry so is he saying Kevin
Holland MVP are line mother effers or
the people claiming Prime card did 1.3
the people claiming that Prime did 1.3
because that was part of the podcast too
like um he's like there's If he if they
did 1.3 million they would be doing like
10 events a year they did not do
anywhere near that it's so hard to do
1.3 of course yeah and there's no way to
freaking
to you know make sure that that actually
happened no if you're the prime guys
you're going to put a number out there
so you look good
yeah all
righty let's
go here uh so this is just reports it's
not guaranteed but uh Bri oer versus Yar
Rodriguez 2 uh UFC Mexico umud the
winner should get a Ford Lightning
Mexicans love Ford Lightnings they they
love them a winner of Bri so Mexican
Mexican crime the UFC should do a
special edition let your boy build it
and the winner gets a generation 2 Ford
Lightning now these guys are young so
don't know [__] about Ford Lightnings
but their Mexican Community would
celebrate it yeah it'd be a big
promotion we get Ford involved they hire
me to let build this thing out I get my
posy together dude no brainer make it
happen I feel like ortego would dig it
more more but um agree I feel like yeah
you're like
car wheels but yeah the last time they
fought remember it was like a freak
injury with his shoulder for Ortega so
apparently this is going to take place
on February 24th and on that same card
it's supposed to be Brandon Marino
versus Air tough fight for br our boy
Brandon I love Brandon o Amir is a
monster oh I don't love that but I love
Brandon
MH but that's where he's at you know he
just lost the champ so
um
okay let's see what do you think about
this Matt Brown thinks that if there was
love Matt Brown if there was an MMA
fight between Jake Paul and Nate Diaz
Jake would still
win let me take this in for a second you
have the immortal taking Jake Paul's
side he says he would probably win
yeah we already know he can outbox him
when it was the last time you saw Nate
take somebody down agree but I don't
think you'll be able to take him down
even if he tries he's way way underz
Jake Paul's much bigger than him I don't
know the weight it will be at probably
85 Nate's not a great wrestler facts
it's going to end up stay on the feet
what difference would be from their
boxing match if it stays on their
feet what about leg kicks you think Nate
could just chop him down like if you
haven't been kicked in the leg that's
going to affect the stand up
no I agree with the immortal
here I agree leg kicks is something you
got to think about and and Jake would
train for that but Jake's power with 4 o
gloves on and Nate's not you know some
of the Jitsu trips could get Jake in
some trouble if that fight goes to the
ground it's over so fast but I I would
put Jake at a minus
105 it's a close close fight because the
ground this thing's over but Jake's
going to hit pretty hard a but the one
cavy out there Immortal knows us better
than anybody you know he knows more
about fighting than I do but the the
distance is different in MMA so Jake
would have to adjust to that because
he's been doing so much boxing same
thing as he MMA guys come over to boxing
the distance is different so everyone
goes I don't get it in MMA he he was so
good at this it's just a different dance
a different sport so I think Jake it
would take a little bit of a learn curve
MMA so new and and Nate's such a veteran
when it comes to it so it could be even
even money or you even you could even
now I'm going back a little bit what I
said could even go Nate minus 105 just
because his experience in the Octagon
the distance if it goes to the ground
this thing's over and Jake it's like
yeah better boxer but if that doesn't
work out who knows and they're like yeah
but Jake Russell in high school I've
never I haven't seen [__] I haven't seen
I haven't seen him defend it take I
don't know I'm sure he's working on it
so i' probably lean a little bit and
when it comes to the odds with Nate
because of the experience and we know
what he brings inside there and Jake
this unknown but I I I to a certain
degree I agree with Matt on
this okay the immortal can do no wrong
in my
book um some one Championship news
shinya Aoki and Sage northcut they were
supposed to fight before but then uh
Sage had some like issues with covid so
they couldn't go through it but they're
rebooked now for fight I like that fight
for sage he's coming off that big win in
Denver one championship in Denver so I'm
excited for this Aoki still doing the
damn thing a he dude he I don't know
what's up with him but he's legend in
the sport oh that's a good card in Tokyo
January 28th you got ratang versus
takaro yeah North cut and Aoki all right
take my money one championship and
speaking of one dude one's coming with
some sauce for that ass chin for the
first time ever you got one fight night
17 on Prime Amazon Prime this freaking
Friday I'll be in Chicago but have it on
the Green Room uh I'm in Chicago this
Friday Saturday but December 8th at 8:00
p.m. Eastern on Prime Video Amazon Prime
video it's one fight night 17 for the
first time ever you have the one
Championship will broadcast a card in
the US Prime Time where every single
fight will be in one Muay Thai what's
one Muay Thai I'm glad you asked
Fighters must engage constantly they
can't stall otherwise they get warnings
kind of like the price days and then
it's Muay Thai in 4 o gloves all right
you get three three minute rounds so
it's not like this long drawn out thing
they have to engage it is action-packed
if you like fistic cuffs if you like to
see Knockouts by the most talented
people that can kick punch and elbow on
this freaking planet tune in Friday
night at 8:00 pm Eastern how about my
boy Roman is from Ukraine he's
67 his record is 49 and S you think the
guy knows a thing or two about
kickboxing Muay Thai well he's a world
champion he won the inaugural one light
heavyweight kickboxing World title back
in November in 2019 he defended twice
moved up to division to heavyweight then
won the one heavyweight kickboxing World
Grand Prix in November of 2022 now he's
switching it up going from the inaugural
one heavyweight Muay Thai World
Championship all right he's so much damn
fun to watch this guy's an absolute
freak he's 67 from Ukraine and can fight
do you need any other convincing the guy
he's fighting is from Australia his name
is Alexy
63 who do you got I'm taking the Roman
Ukraine guy 143 but he did just claim
the WBC heavyweight Muay Thai World
title this past October but I'll take my
boy Roman at 67 and from being Ukraine
it's going to be problems but our boy
smok and Joe and Luke the chef lesie the
Muay Thai featherweight Championship
smoking Joe listen to this 71 and 11
he's currently ranked number four um
he's known for his crazy knockout P if
you haven't watched smok and Joe you're
in for a treat then Luke the chef he's
5-0 undefeated American fighter he's won
all his fights via knockout so
somebody's getting put to sleep smoking
Joe the chef somebody going to bed all
right and then uh one of my favorite
guys on the card is this boy we call
Johan ready for this Johan's 23 and six
and he was he's 16 years old he was 16
years old he was he's 17 now but he was
at that time 23 and six 16 years old
beaten up grown ass men knocked three
dudes out he ear a six figure contracted
won Championship last month he's 17 now
he's viewed as and this is a High Praise
he's viewed as the next rat Tang which
is insane rat Tang is like the guy the
absolute guy 16-year-old knocking grown
men out he's their next Superstar he's
fighting Edgar you we I saw him fight in
Denver I if I recall he's 32 and7 he
made history when he became the first
Mexican athlete to win the WBC Muay Thai
not Mexico's not known for their Muay
Thai and this Mexican's doing it all
right so he's fighting this kid he's 17
now that's an age you should bring up J
of note he's
17's like before we go his girlfriend is
34 35 I just want to throw that out
there I know he's 23 and six but his
girlfriend's 34
that's going down this Friday 8:00 pm
Eastern on Amazon Prime it's one
Championship the best Muay Thai in the
world in 4 o gloves what come on it's a
great product man I'm excited for
it uh quick little break speaking of
great products chane great segue here
this episode of the shop show at 700 a.m
is brought to you by happy hippo the
best crom on planet Earth however you
get katum if you you want to try it you
can't just trust anybody you got to
trust the one the only happy hippo for
God's sakes how many times I have to
tell you guys in any form you want your
creatum tablets taffies shots energy
shots K dips they got it all for your
ass all right ran out of words there
just go to happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 3 C's th h i CCC 23 you get 20%
off for Life share with your friends
families whoever wants to try create
them if you're trying a different
company guarantee you happy hippo Does
It Better all you got to do is go to
happy hippo.com promo code is th23 for
the very best product to get your ass
ready for the morning your workouts
podcasting at work Zone in it's catom
it's happy
hippo all right that should be enough
for currents and then we also have a USC
coming up this weekend as well now
remember this UFC is supposed to be in
uh China but then pan got hurt so they
went you know what let's bring this
thing back to Vegas so you got song
versus Chris Gutierrez which is a fun
fight the comain event is my favorite
you got Anthony Smith uh who's the
nicest guy in the plant best teeth in
the UFC versus Cleo round treat both my
boys won't pick a winner here but I
can't wait this has a some title
implications whoever wins this light
heavyweights up in the air whoever gets
like a convincing knockout could be
right in that title shot conversations
got anony Smith Cleo Round Tree again
UFC giving you a pretty tasty Fight
Night for free okay Sona dong Chris gz
Anthony Smith Cleo rry uh Nas rat's
always fun Jamie Malarkey that might be
the best fight on the card uh Park Jung
young you also got the what do they call
them the iron Turtle Park iron Turtle
Park Jong young the iron turtle looks
like a turtle when you when you think of
this look him up he looks like an iron
Turtle it might be the best nickname in
all of sports it's Park the iron Turtle
Jung young and I'm all for it uh what
time is that at since the Apex normal
7:00 p.m. at Apex I don't know why
that's on Saturday so you have yourself
a nice little weekend what I want you to
do is order yourself a large pepperoni
pizza from Domino's get extra sauce so
you know it's fresh even if you don't
like the sauce if you just ask for a
regular pizza it's going to be old one
that get off the shelves you order it
with extra sauce it comes hot piping
into your door you do that on Friday at
8:00 p.m. Eastern you watch the one ch
ship Muay Thai World Championship Muay
Thai it's going to be fun Ukrainian 67
knocking dudes out all right then you
got the 16-year-old doing the damn thing
he's 17 now but you know what I mean you
eat that pizza you watch one
Championship on Amazon Prime at 8:00 pm
Eastern then Saturday you do the same
freaking thing you order that pizza
extra sauce again it's comes piping hot
and you watch UFC Fight Night Apex
Center Cleo round Tre Anthony Smith
that's your weekend enjoy your weekend
that's that's the show I'm off addiction
Motorsports to fix my freaking truck I
won't shut up about thank you guys
hopefully it gets fixed or my day is
ruined hope you enjoyed the show it's
live we messed up on one read Because J
didn't Overlook it I'm going take a hard
cold hand to his face I'm Chicago this
Friday and Saturday it's my son's
freaking Little League game so you guys
better come out that's this Friday two
shows Friday 700 to 9:30 two shows
Saturday 700 to 9:30 then January end of
January I'm in Nashville one night only
January 25th I'm in Austin Texas January
26 27th get your freaking tickets at
thick boy.com thanks for tuning in wish
me luck also for all those of you that
sent me the W the well wishes for the
baby girl she came home three days after
that she's all fine and dandy she's
getting thicker thank God she's great
than can't thank you guys enough I'm
very blessed love you
guys thanks for watching good
morning
that